We got a new backdrop!
Thanks Flame Challenge!
Hey Crazies.
I’ve been thinking, there’s an idea we
haven’t given enough thought.
Inertia.
We defined it in a previous video.
An object’s ability to resist changes in motion.
But then Question Clone got involved.
What does that really mean?
And, well, I just can’t help but answer
the guy’s questions.
First, let’s get some perspective with a
little history.
Even though real science started with Galileo,
the story of motion starts much much earlier.
Back when exact dates are a little hazy,
there was this guy named Aristotle
in Ancient Greece.
and he had some very bad ideas.
Introducing Aristotle Clone.
The natural state of all things is to be at
rest.
If you impart motion to a book, does it not
stop of its own accord?
Get! Get out! Shoe!
How dare you! Do you know who I am?!
You’re just a clone of Aristotle.
Anyway, I know I’ve said this before but
I’ll repeat it as many times as it takes.
Aristotle was almost always wrong.
But his ideas sounded pretty believable,
so humans were convinced he was right for
about 2000 years.
Fast forward to Galileo.
Real science began when Galileo started doing
experiments.
You know, actually testing our ideas before
claiming them as fact.
Galileo discovered something very important:
Relativity.
No no no, not the Einsteinian relativity,
just basic relativity.
We did a whole video on it as part of a series,
but here’s the too long don’t watch version:
Steady motion in a straight line for one observer
could easily be no motion for another observer.
Therefore, they are the same type of motion: Inertial Motion.
Inertial, as in Inertia, as in Inert-sha. Eh?
Root words for the win!
The point is, when Aristotle said this:
The natural state of all things is to be at rest.
He should have also included steady motion
in a straight line,
because that’s indistinguishable from being
at rest.
And this brings us to Newton and the Principia
Mathematica.
I have a copy of this somewhere.
Ah! Here it is.
Let's read, shall we?
Law 1: Every body perseveres in its state
of being at rest or of moving uniformly straight forward.
Newton’s first law of motion actually defines
inertia.
It’s a tendency things have to stay still
or keep steadily moving
like this,
or like this,
or even this,
If you want to know what that car video is all about,
go check it out on my friend Jesse’s channel.
He works out the math behind it too.
But didn’t that car just stop?
Yeah, because there’s this pesky thing on
Earth called friction.
Without the friction, it would have just gone on forever.
The point I’m trying to make here is that inertia
is not a force.
I repeat, inertia is not a force!
When you take all the forces away, inertia
is what remains.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Please subscribe if you want to keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
In the last video, we discussed where size
comes from.
Comment response time!
Mr Coffis isn’t sure what “space” is
anymore.
Yeah, that’s actually a place we’re pretty
stuck right now.
In quantum physics, it’s just an environment in which
things play out.
It doesn’t really affect any of the interactions.
In general relativity, it’s something tangible
that can be stretched and twisted.
But it still has to be a continuous "fabric," otherwise
the equations aren’t valid.
Either way though, it’s kind of just there
and isn’t made of anything more fundamental.
Joel Craig always assumed space was energy
fields.
Well, like I said in the previous answer,
space is just kind of there.
In fact, it has to already be there for our
models to work.
Even in Quantum Field Theory, there’s an
energy field for every type of fundamental
particle, but those fields have to exist in
a space.
That’s what a “field” is.
It’s a value assigned to every point in
space.
No space means no field.
Pablo Perez was wondering if a calculus differential
was the same as a single point.
Definitely not.
It’s always the space between two points.
Say you’ve got a point at 5 and a
point at 7.
The difference is 2, so that’s like saying
the points are at 5 and 5+2.
Everybody still with me?
You could make the points closer by moving
the second point to 5+1,
or 5+0.1, or 5+0.000001.
If you make the difference so small that you
can’t hope to measure it,
then the difference is called a “differential.”
We say that one is at 5 and 5+dx,
that little tiny space,
but those are still two different points.
Same goes for volumes.
Little volume increments are made of 8 different
points
and, depending on your choice of coordinates,
can have different shapes.
But that’s because differentials always
have some size.
Diodoubled wants to know what String Theory
has to say about this.
They definitely go with solution #3:
points have size.
Which reminds me,
I asked you which of the three solutions you
thought was correct.
Infinities, unoccupiable spots, or points
with size.
“Points with size” was the winner by consensus,
although not by much.
Because very few of you actually voted in
the comments.
Come on crazies! Work with me here!
We did have some very witty people in the
comments this time.
Much appreciated.
Anyway, thanks for watching, everybody! See you in the comments.